you a gambling man jack
not anymore once a camping man always
gambling man
let's go let's go toss up a coin
one side you your family live the life
they always dreamed of
on the other side you lose
everything you owe a lot of money to
some very bad people
so i bought your debt now you're gonna
have to repay me that debt
can we just get to the job
it's a legend in the underground and to
those who know
it's the money plane a bulletproof
casino in the sky
untouchable by any government agency
whatever you want to wager on the money
plane has you covered
russia or it is they carry up to a
billion on board
crypto and millions in
i cash you and your crew to take down
the house
that's insane yeah heck might even be a
good time
now without further ado sit back relax
and prepare for take-off
who's next
[Music]
you're dead your families are all dead
you your crew and everyone you ever met
dead
by the time you touch down
[Music]
[Applause]
now bring me my money
you